♪
Welcome to the Thinkabit Lab.
Today we'll learn about servos.
What are servos?
Servos are these little guys.
They are motors
that you can program,
that you can control.
Why would that be important?
Have you ever wanted
to build a robot?
Or control the way
something moves?
You can use servos
to do that.
We're going to use
two different kinds of servos.
This small one
is a position-based servo,
and the big one
is a continuous servo.
The big one, you can control
the speed and direction
in which it spins,
and it spins 360 degrees.
The small one,
you can program its position.
This one is 180-degree range,
but you can buy
a 90-degree-range servo,
270-degree-range servo,
depending on what you want.
So, we're going to program
a very simple example for these,
something that you can
manipulate and control.
First, look at how
there are three wires
coming out of your servo.
The red and black
power the motor,
and the white is the signal
it's looking for to control it.
It's called the PWM signal--
pulse-width modulation--
and it's looking
for a specific shape.
Like your heart rate,
a PWM is a specific shape.
We don't want
to program for that,
so in Arduino, there's a library
we can reference to use it.
So, let's get started
by connecting your Arduino
to your computer
using a USB cable.
Connect your USB cable
to your Arduino,
and then connect that
to your computer.
It takes a moment
for the Arduino
to register on your computer.
Once it has, go to
"Tools: Find Port"
and choose the com port number
that's associated with Arduino.
Go ahead and click that,
Then I like to go to "File: New"
and expand that window...
and delete
everything inside.
I say Control-A and backspace,
and I do that
because I like to write code
from scratch
with this exercise.
Next, I want us
to get that library.
The library that will generate
the signal that we need,
go to
"Sketch: Include Library,"
and then we click on "Servo."
Then it pops up
with that line of code.
Then we want to name
our servo.
Write S-e-r-v-o,
space "myservo"...
and then semicolon.
That let's the code
and the Arduino know
that we're using a servo.
Then what I'd like us to do
is to attach our servo
to the right pin number.
To do that,
look at our Arduino
and notice on the digital side
there's a parentheses
that says PWM
with a squiggly line next to it.
And notice that
3, 5, 6, 9, 10, and 11
have that squiggly line
next to it.
That means that those pins
can generate the PWM
that the servo needs to move.
We're gonna go ahead
and use 9.
In our void setup,
this is where we can set up
our Arduino's hardware.
So, "void setup," all lowercase,
open, close parentheses,
open bracket--
shift next to the letter "P"--
enter, and it automatically
generates that close bracket,
and make sure your cursor's
in between those two brackets.
We'll attach our servo here.
So, we write "myservo.attach,"
and then write 9 inside
and then semicolon.
Essentially, pin 9
is going to control our servo.
The next thing I want to do
is write a void loop.
This is where
the action happens.
The lines in the void loop
run over and over again.
We're gonna write "void loop,"
open, close parentheses,
open bracket, enter.
Notice the close bracket,
and we'll write
our lines of code inside there.
The code that I wanna write
could be used for both servos.
So, the first line,
"myservo.write(0);"--
this line of code
for the continuous servo
will have it spinning
to the left really fast.
For a small servo,
it'll go to position 0 degrees.
How do I know that?
With the small servo,
it's intuitive.
I'll discuss that later.
The big servo's
not intuitive.
We'll look into how
we can use a number line
to understand what numbers
correlate to what actions.
We'll do that certain action
for a certain amount of time,
so our next line
will be "delay."
We'll use the value 2000
and then semicolon.
So 2000 milliseconds
is 2 seconds.
The big servo
will spin left fast
for two seconds.
The small servo
will go to position 0 degrees
for two seconds,
but only if
we keep writing code.
Otherwise, it wouldn't
make sense to have a delay.
Let's keep writing:
"myservo.right(180)."
And then "delay 2000."
Looking at our void loop,
this tells me that our big servo
is gonna spin left
for two seconds
and right
for two seconds,
and keeps doing that.
The small servo will go
to position 0 degrees,
then position 180 degrees,
then position 0 degrees.
We want to see that happen,
so we'll upload our code.
Push the arrow pointing right.
Once it's uploaded,
let's start connecting them.
Start with the big servo.
Take your red, black,
and white wire,
and make sure
they're color-coded.
We color-code wires
because it makes it easier
and less likely
to actually make mistakes.
Put black wire to black,
red to red, and white to white.
Again, black and red
are your power.
Black goes GND,
or the negative side of power.
Red can go into VIN,
although some people use 5V.
And white
is where you programmed it
in your void setup, pin 9.
Notice this servo spins to
the left and then to the right
and then to the left.
It's fully rotating, which only
a continuous servo can do.
The position-based servo
will not fully rotate.
Right? It's position-based.
But let's look
at the small servo.
Take out the wires,
and be careful that
they don't touch each other.
And then plug in
the small servo
to see how the same code
behaves differently
with each servo.
So, this servo
goes to position 180,
then 0,
then 180,
then 0.
How do I know it's 0?
It's relative.
Depends on where
you want to reference it.
I'm going to decide
this is 0
and that's 180.
It's not perfect.
A more expensive servo
will be more precise.
Let's start changing
our code.
Let's see what happens
if we manipulate it a bit.
Before I do that,
I want to share with you
the number line
for a big servo.
I'll unplug this
for a moment.
And so you're aware,
the values you can use
for both servos,
according to this library,
is 0 to 180.
Okay? Those are
the only values you can use
for myservo.write
in that parentheses.
So, for a full-rotation,
continuous servo,
we're gonna use
a number line.
So, we're gonna say
0 is here,
and then over here
is going to be 180.
So, 180 divided by 2 is 90.
That's about halfway.
And 90
for a continuous servo
is stop.
I'll put that
in quotation marks,
'cause it's not perfect.
Sometimes you put 91;
sometimes 89.
It's trial and error
to make it stop.
Choosing a value
to the right of 90
will make your servo
spin to the right.
Choosing a value
to the left of 90
will make your servo
spin to the left.
And I said you can control
the speed and direction
in which it spins.
Looking at my fingers,
the further away you get
from 90, the faster you go.
The closer you get to 90,
the slower you go.
If you want the fastest
it can go,
you can only use 0 and 180.
And again, to go slower,
just get closer
to the value of 90.
And the small servo
is more intuitive.
The value you put
inside the parentheses
is the angle
it will point to.
So, for
the position-based servo,
if I say myservo.write(0),
I go to 0 degrees.
If I say, myservo .write(90),
I go to 90 degrees.
If I say, myservo.write(180),
I go to 180 degrees.
Let's play around with some
examples using the big servo.
You can change values
in the delay
or change change values
in myservo.write
inside those parentheses.
Let's start with delay,
and instead of 2000,
let's put 200
and see what happens.
It's gonna shimmy,
because 200 milliseconds
is not enough time
for it to fully rotate.
It will shimmy, and it drifts
a bit, so be wary of that.
Using the small one, it will
shimmy, but it won't drift.
Maybe I don't want it
to go back and forth.
I want it
to only go one way.
I'll erase
three lines of code.
I only want it
to do one thing.
I want it to spin
slowly to the right.
I'll use the value 100.
I'm gonna upload that.
Notice it spins
to the right slowly.
And if you were to use
that line of code
and switch it
to the small servo,
you're telling it to go
to position 100
and not do anything.
So, students will be like,
"My servo's broken."
Watch what happens
when I plug it in.
Went to position 0
and it stopped.
You can feel
that you can't move it,
but it's not very strong
and could break easily.
You need at least
four lines of code
for the position-based servo.
I'll show you
the example of the shimmy
on a position-based servo.
But at least with this one,
it will not drift.
I encourage you to change values
in your myservo.write.
Change values
in your delay.
Write more lines of code
in your brackets,
and see what you
can do with it.
I hot-glue items on there
to see them move.
Maybe you want to get
something crawling.
But have fun, see what it
can do, and enjoy yourselves.
Thanks.
Funding to purchase and make
this educational production
accessible was provided by the
U.S. Department of Education.
PH:1-800-USA-LEARN (V)
or WEB: www.ed.gov.